[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر براكي
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربي
اتفاق امريكيون اسرائيليون على منع ايران
من السلاح النووي وضربه اصفهان قد تكون
اكبر واعقد من المعلن
[موسيقى]
مسلسل الدبابات يتكرر بولندا مستعده لمد
كياف بالاف سته عشر شرط الاجماع ومكروه لا
يستبعد المبدا
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
مائده الست تعدو بخطه اصلاح تطيح باردوغان
وتفصل بين السلطات لكن مرشحها لمنافسته لم
يظهر بعد
[موسيقى]
عناويننا عن ماكرون يقول لا ينبغي استخدام
الاسلحه التي ارسلناها لاوكرانيا في الدرب
الاراضي الروسيه وارسال طائرات مقاتله الى
اوكرانيا يجب ان لا يتسبب في ضعف الجيش
الفرنسي وارسال مقاتلات لاوكرانيا
الامريكيه التي تستمر في المنطقه في
محاوله
الصعيدي بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ليؤكد بعدها على ضروره اتخاذته
على الاسراء
استقرار المنطقه وامريكا بدورها مستمره في
دعم التمسك بالوضع القائم في المواقع
المقدسه في القدس
الفلسطيني احمد الديك اهلا بك سيد احمد
يعني تصريحات بلينكن في المؤتمر الصحفي
الذي جمعه
برئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني همم نتنياهو لم
تخرج عن المالوف في اللوم الجانب
الفلسطيني اكثر من الجانب الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي ما الذي تنتظرونه من هذه الزياره
ما الخطوط الحمراء التي ستطالبون بوضعها
وما ضمنات
يسعد مساك اولا ااا ثانيا اييه نحن نرحب
باي جهد امريكي ودوله مبذول لتحقيق
التهدئه ووقف التصعيد اييه ثانيا نحن
معنيون بتعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه مع
الاداره الامريكيه
ثالثا فيما يتعلق بالصراع كل ما نطلبه من
الاداره الامريكيه ومن السيد بلنكن هو ااه
ترجمه الاقوال الى افعال
وتحويل الوعود والمواقف التي تعلنها
الاداره الامريكيه الى خارطه الطريق
واليات عمليه ملزمه لدوله الاحتلال
وللحكومه الاسرائيليه لوقف جميع اشكال
التصعيد والخطوات احاديه الجانب لا يجوز
ان يتم المساواه بين الضحيه والجلات بصيغه
اننا ندعو جميع الاطراف نحن شعب تحت
احتلال كل يوم نقتل وتصادر اراضينا
وتقتحم مدننا ومخيماتنا وقرانا المق ساعه
توست تباح هل هل اعتقادك بانه الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه بما تبقى لها من وقت
همم قادره وفي نفس الوقت تريد ان تضغط على
همم حكومه نتنياهو لكي تتنازل لكي تقدم
شيئا همم
كي تقرن الاقوال بالافعال كما طلبتهم
نعم نحن لدينا قناه تامه اذا ارادت
الاداره الامريكيه تستطيع ان تضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لوقف جميع الاجراءات
احاديه الجانب وتستطيع اجبارها على
الانخراط في عمليه سياسيه همم ومفاوضات
جاده بين الجانبين تفضل لانهاء الاحتلال
وفقا لقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
استلام العربيه واذا لم تلتزم او توافق
الحكومه الاسرائيليه على هذه الضغوط ليقف
السيد كلينتون والاداره الامريكيه ويقول
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه هي التي تتحمل
المسؤوليه اما ان يتم المساواه بين الضحيه
والجلاد هذا ليس عدلا ان يبقى السيد
كلينتون والاداره السيد بلينكن والاداره
الامريكيه يقولون اننا مع الحقوق
المتساويه
للاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين انا اتسائل همم
اين هي الحقوق المتساويه بيننا وبين
الاسرائيليين نحن نقدر الحقوق لقوانين
تمييزيه لقوانين عنصريه همم
اليوم في اسرائيل يعني طرح مبادره فكره ما
همم يعني عندكم معلومات عن هالموضوع وانتم
بالتالي بكرا شو راح تقولوا لبنك يعني شو
راح تطلبوا همم وعلى ماذا يمكن ان توافقوا
من عدمه في هذه المرحله
اولا نحن السيد الرئيس محمود عباس
والقياده الفلسطينيه
سيطالبون بوقف جميع الاجراءات العقربيه
التي اتخذتها حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو في
همم اولا الاخيره ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
وقيادته همم بما في ذلك همم سرقه اموال
الشعب الفلسطيني بما في ذلك ما يسمونه
بالثوره الاستنطانيه بما في ذلك فرض
العقوبات على القياده الفلسطينيه تمت
اجراءات ثمه مجزره هذا اليوم حصلت في هدم
المنازل في القدس بدون اي سبب وهذا خارج
القانون عمليات اجتياحات للمدن والقرى
والمخيمات الفلسطينيه بما تخلفه من عمليات
الوضحايه
همم
بحل الدولتين بانه الحل الامثل هل يمكن
فعلا المضيء بهذا الموضوع هذه همم هذا
الطرح هل هو قابل
لتنفيذ بهذا بوجود حكومه مثل الحكومه
ما يفعله اليمين المتطرف بالايام همم
الماضيه
اولا المطلوب من الاداره الامريكيه ليس
فقط ان تعلن مرارا وتكرارا تمسكها بحاله
دولتين عليها ان تتخذ مجم- سلسله من
الاجراءات لحمايه حل الدولتين من غولي
الاستيطان الذي يلتهم الارض الفلسطينيه
اين ستقام الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله في
ظل الاستمرار الاستيطان ثالث نعم تستطيع
الاداره الامريكيه ان تطلق عمليه سلام
وتجبر الحكومه الاسرائيليه كما تم اجبار
سمير في فتره من الفترات على الانقراض في
عمليه سياسيه في العاده اليمين الاسرائيلي
يستطيع ان يقدم تنازلات وانقرض في عمليه
سياسيه افضل من الحكومات السابقه اما يجب
لا يجوز ان يبقى الشعب الفلسطيني يدفع
تاره زمن الحكومه اسرائيليه ضعيفه كما
سميت حكومه لبيت ولا يجوز ان ندفع ايضا
الثمن حكومه اسرائيليه سميت يمنيه
ومتطرفه ما هي مواصفات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
التي يجب على الشعب الفلسطيني ان ينتظرها
حتى يحل السلام وكم سندفع كشعب فلسطيني
ثمن
للانتظام الانتظار هذه الحكومه شكرا جزيلا
لك المستشار السياسي لوزير الخارجيه
الفلسطيني سيد احمد الديك تحياتي اليك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
حسب خبره البسيطه يعني الامريكان هما
حلفاء الاسرائيليين
والشعب الفلسطيني بطل متوقع يعني من هذول
الدول انه يعني يكون في لنا اي همم
ايجابيات على الارض لانه احنا جربناهم على
مدار اكثر من 25 سنه همم كل المرات كانت
تكون في وعودات همم في
مفاوضات واشياء اخرى بس ال- همم ما تحقق
للشعب الفلسطيني اي نتائج على الارض والله
اكيد ما في اي تفائل يعني اكيد همم
الموقف الامريكي واضح للفلسطينيين ولا
العالم كله انما مع اسرائيل 100%
وهمم وفي القدم وفي ال- همم في همم في
الوضع الحالي يعني ما ما تغيرش اشي مش راح
يتغير شيء ممكن يعني انت بتحكي عن قطب
دوله اللي هو امريكا يعني
واضح الانحياز الامريكي المفرط الاسرائيلي
هذا شيء معروف بديهي ولكن وجود وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي هنا لدى السلطه
الفلسطينيه يثير تساؤلات يعني بمعنى اخر
يمكن ان نخرج بشيء ولو يعني دون الحد
المطلوب ممكن يعني هو مجرد وجوده مثير
للاستغراب يعني يدل ان هناك ازمه او هناك
خطوه يعني يمكن ان يتم اتخاذها
[موسيقى]
في جانب اخر من زياره بلنكن للمنطقه راويه
وكده رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
الثانيه
على سياسه المشتركه لمنع حصول ايران على
السلاح النوويه
هذا السلاح
التي اكدنا من خلالها اننا نتوافق مع
امريكا على سياسه مشتركه تمنعها حصول
ايران على سلاح النووي هناك اجماع على ان
النظام الايراني لا ينبغي ان يحوز السلاح
النووي
ايران من الحصول على سلاح النووي وسنقوم
بكل ما في وسعيناه لتحقيق ذلك شخصيا سافعل
كل شيء لمنع ايران من حيازه اسلحه النوويه
وكل الاسرائيليين على علم بحجم الدعم
امريكيه لمنظومه الدفاعيه
الاسرائيلي كوهين لنظيره الامريكي انطوني
على اهميه العمل المشترك ضد ايران وبحسب
صحيفه تايم اوف استرايل ابدا كوهين
اهتماما خاصا للعمل المشترك بشان تعطيل
البرنامج النووي الايراني شدد على اهميه
ادراج جميع حلفائها بما في ذلك فيلقوا
الحرس الثوري الايراني في قائمه المنظمات
في اصفهان الايرانيه والتي تحدثت وقت
جورنال عن ان اسرائيل تقف خلفها تحمل
الكثير من الخبايا
مع زياره المرشد الايراني
لمعارض الانجازات الصناعيه الذي تتضمن
بالتحديد انجازات الطائرات المسيره
عن مصادر استخباراتيه غربيه واجنبيه قولها
ان الهجوم سجل نجاحا هائلا خلافا لمزاعم
النظام الايراني اما يبعوث فقالت ان
الضربه تستهدفته تعمل فيها ايران على
تطوير صواريخ فرض صوتيه والمفاجاه هنا
بحسب الصحيفه ان المشروعه تم بمساعده
الروسيه
وقالت ان هدفها هو تعطيل محاولات العوده
الى الاتفاق النووي نقطه اخرى مهمه في هذه
الضربه مستشار
رئيس الاكرانيا عن ان منطقه الحرب في
اوكرانيا لا يرحم وقاتل وانها تحاسب
المتواطئين في اشاره لتزويد ايران لروسيا
بالمساراته عدائيا واستدعت القائم
بالاعمال الاوكراني لديها للاحتجاج بل
وهدد مسؤول ايراني اوكرانيا بموقف سياسيا
مختلف من الحرب القائمه على اراضيها اذا
لم تصحح هذه التصريحات العاديه
[موسيقى]
سلاح ايران المفضل
ارسلتها تهران الى كل مكان حيث ميليشياتها
في سوريا والعراق واليمن ولعب دورا في حرب
الوكاله لتزيين الموقف وتهديد الممرات
المائيه لتنفيذ مشروعها الخاص المسيرات
الانتحاريه التي تجمعها ايران تستخدمها
كورقه ضغط لتحقيق مكاسب في المفاوضات
النوويه او لرفع العقوبات
[موسيقى]
لطالما كان الغرب يفكر باليه للحد من سلوك
ايران ومسيراتها وما حدث في اصفهان كان
رساله لتغيير في الاستراتيجيه
مسيرات من داخل البلاد تضرب موقعا عسكريا
هذه المره في ايران وجود خلايا واختراق
داخل ايران مساله تتصاعد حيث كان البرنامج
النووي الايراني هدفا لمحاولات تخريب
متكرره في عام 2020 اغتيل كبير العلماء في
البلاد وتعرضت منشاه طنز النوويه لاضرار
الجزئيه وفي العام نفسه تم ضرب منشات كراج
مسيرات اصفهان ضربت مصنع اسلحه حكوميه
الايرانيه في وسط مدينه اصفهان والذي
تصادف ايضا ان يكون مركزا لانتاج مسيرات
يقال انها ترسل الى القوات الروسيه
بكرانيه
تصريحات اوكرانيا لطهران بعد الهجوم باننا
حذرناكم ورد روسيا العنيف لادانه الهجوم
كلها اسباب تؤكد هذا التوجه وقبلها تحدث
اعلام امريكي عن ان اسرائيل هي من نفذت
الهجوم ومهما يكن من امر فانه جوما اصفهان
يشكل نقطه تحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
واطهران بنقل المواجهه الى داخله ايران
نفسها التي تواجه احتجاجات ضد النظام الذي
فقد الحاضنه الشعبيه له
واقف العربيه 360 ايضا
ناقلات هنديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الملف الاوكرانيه
ازدادوا الحديث عن امكانيه تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات اف 16 كنا بالدبابات هلا صرنا
بالمقاتل
لم يستبعد الفكره اما رئيس الوزراء
البولنديه ماتيوز موراوسكي فقال ان نقل
مقاتله او طائرات افست عشر الى اوكرانيا
ممكن فقط بالتنسيق الوثيقي مع حلفاء
الناتو مثل ما حدث في ملف دبابات
الايجابيه من بولندا في ملف المقاتلات
في الاثناء يبحث عن نيته عن زياده الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا حتى من دول لا تنتمي
للحلفه
على زياده دعمها في مقابل ما تقدمه كوريا
الشماليه لروسيا
الشماليه
فانما يحدث هنا مهم ايضا لحلف شمال
الاطلسي وما يحدث في اوروبا مهم لاسيا
البلدان التي تؤمن بالحريه
يجب ان تساعد بعضها البعض لاننا نرى ان
القوه لاستبداديه تقترب اكثر فاكثر
الاصوات الاوروبيه المعارضه
لان ذلك يؤدي فقط الى اطاله امام الحرب مع
روسيا
وتسائل حول الهدف الحقيقيه طاهر من خطه
ارسال الدبابات الغربيه الصنع
الاتحاد
لا يمكنه منع الدول الافريقيه تحديدا من
التبادل التجاري مع روسيا صح
اذا كانت الدول الافريقيه رغبه بالتبادل
التجاري مع روسيا في هذه الحاله ما باليد
حيله لا يمكننا يمكنني منهم من ذلك
هناك شيء اخر لا يستطيع بري ولا الغرب
بشكل عام ان يمنعه ان يمنعه وهو دخول
النفط الروسي للسوق فالختلاف على ان الحرب
الميدانيه في اوكرانيا توازيها حرب
اقتصاديه اخذت اشكال مختلفه ابرزها حرب
الطاقه التي اشعلت اسعار المحروقات حول
العالم روسيا التي تعد ثالث اكبر منتج
للنفط في العالم وجدت نفسها مضطره للتكيف
مع الوضع الجديد الذي فرض عليها بعد
العقوبات الصادره من المعسكر الغربي موسكو
نجحت لحد الان في ايجاد بدائل مكانتها من
تجاوز العقوبات الغربيه ولو مرحله والدليل
هو ان انتاج روسيا من النفط لم يتراجع بعد
مرور نحو شهرين على بدء تطبيق العقوبات
الغربيه
فكيف التفت موسكو على هذه العقوبات قبل
الحديث عن مخرج الروسي يجب توضيح الطبيعه
العقوبات التي فرضتها الدول الغربيه هذا
مهم فالعقوبات التي اعلنت عنها مجموعه سبع
تضمنت حضره استيراد النفط الروسي في
اوروبا لتنضم الاخيره بذلك الى الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا في هذا السياق اضافه
الى ذلك تم تسقيفه سعر النفط الروسيه عند
60 دولارا للبرميل في الاسواق الاخرى كما
تقتضي عقوبه سقف السعر منع الشركات
الغربيه من توفير ناقلات لشحن نفط الروسي
فضلا عن منع تقديم خدمات التامين للنقل
البحري للناقلات اذا كان النفط مشحون اذا
كان سعره اعلى من سقف السعر المحدد
[موسيقى]
صحيفه
حتى اذا كيف استمر تدفق
الى مختلف الاسواق العالميه بسعر يتجاوز
سقف المحدد في العقوبات الغربيه
تملك هذه الشركات المتواجده في مومباي
ناقلات حصلت عليها بعد بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وهو مصطلح يطلق على الناقلات المستعده
للالتفاف على العقوبات لنقل النفط الخام
وهي ممارسه شائعه تستخدمها ايران كذلك
فنزويلا منذ فتره طويله لتجنب عقوبه النفط
الغربيه
الظل مملوكه لشركات خارجيه في بلدان ذات
قوانين اكثر تساهلا كابتنما وليبيا كما ان
اب ناقلات اسطول الظل لديهم معلومات
محدوده مع حكومات او بنوك الولايات
المتحده او الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي فان
خوفهم من التعرض للعقوبات يبقى محدوده
كانت هذه هي طريقه الالتفاف على العقوبات
لكن كيف ردت روسيا على العقوبات ذاتها
راويه طبعا نددت روسيا نددت بشده
بالعقوبات الغربيه على صادراتها من التقاء
وبخاصه ملف تسعير نفطها في الاسواق فكما
نعلم مشاهدينا الصادرات الطاقه هي عصب
والاقتصاد الروسي بوتن اختار الرده بالمثل
هيتعلنا حضره صادرات النفط للدول التي
فرضت سقف اسعار على المنتجات البتروليه
الروسيه هذا يعني بان روسيا مطالبه الان
بمواصله البحث عن اسواق بديله للبيع بيع
نفطها بسعر الذي يناسبها وبكميه جيده وهو
ما كانت قد نجحت في تحقيقه من قبل حيث
غيرت الوجه صوب اسواق اسيويه وافريقيه ومن
امريكا اللاتينيه لكن حينها لم تكن قد
صدرت بعض عقوبه سقف السعر على ايه حال فان
هذه العقوبات قد تنقلب على اصحابها فاذا
لم تتمكن روسيا من العثور على عدد كاف من
المشترين والترت في النهايه الى خفض
الانتاج فقد يؤدي ذلك الى استنزاف المخزون
العالمي ما قد يرفع الاسعار مره اخرى هناك
اشكال يطرح ايضا داخل المعسكر الغربي
وتحديدا اوروبا المضطر الان الى البحث
بشكل كلي عن امدادات بديله ومناسبه ايضا
وفي حال فشلت في ذلك فان العقوبات قد
تتسبب في رفع التكاليف تكاليف استيراد
النفط بالنسبه
الاكثر من ذلك هو ان بعض الاطراف قد
تستفيد من هذا الوضع حيث ستكون قادره على
شراء النفط الروسي باسعار منخفضه ثم بيعه
مكررا الى المشترين في الاتحاد الاوروبي
بسعر اعلى بكثير الكلام هنا تحديدا ينصب
ويتوجه الى الصين والهند اذا سيظل الغرب
يحاول وستظل روسيا تحاول على الاقل مع
الجيران الاقرب وهذا ما يعكسه كلام وزير
الخارجيه الباكستانيه الزائر لموسكو هذه
الايام
كوبريشن
ودوليا حتى بين القوه العظمى نحن نقدر
علاقتنا مع روسيا ولا نرى انها مستاء من
التطورات في العلاقات الدوليه كما نقدر
بشكل متساوي علاقاتنا مع الولايات المتحده
واوروبا ستظل باكستان على الدوام صوتا
مؤيدا للسلام والحوار والدبلوماسيه في
المجتمع الدولي
في البلاد بعد سلسله العقوبات التي فرضت
على موسكو وخسارتها لاسواقهم مبيعات ضخمه
لكن ذلك لم يمنع موسكو من بيع الذهب
الاسود بما في ذلك عن طريق البحر الى
اسواق البديله لتبدا روسيا بتوجيه
صادراتها من النفط والغاز الى اسواق جديده
من الدول الاسيويه منها الصين والهند
وتركيا وباكستان
ولكن باسعار الارخص صعوبات تقنيه ستواجه
روسيا ايضا من اجل عاده توجيه صادراتها من
الطاقه ستحتاج روسيا على سبيل المثال الى
توسيع خط انابيب قوه ايبيريا الذي يذهب
الى الصين من اجل زياده ضخ الغاز اليها
ميدانياتك وسط تقدم للقوات الروسيه في
محاور اوجلدار جنوب المقاطعه وفي بخموت
شمال
سوريا
اصاب مبنى سكنيا ما اسقط عددا من الضحايا
والان ولي العهد السعوديه تلقى اتصال من
الرئيس الروسي استعرض خلاله العلاقات بين
البلددين
[موسيقى]
ونتابعه اخر ما يرد عن الاتصال الذي حصل
من الرئيس الروسي بولي العهد السعودي ولي
العهد السعودي والرئيس الروسي اكد على
ضروره تطوير العلاقات
والى المزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من
دنياك رائد الاخضر مراسل العربيه
اخر ما هو مؤكد او غير مؤكد بشان سيطره
قوه فاجنر على مناطق بعينها من عدم ذلك
لانه كيف في تصريحات عبد طرفها
مساء الخير طاهر ورويدا كيف يعني بالفعل
المعارك مستعره في المحور الشمالي من
مقاطعه خاصه حول مدينه باخمه التي يحاول
الجيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر تطويقها
والدخول اليها من من عده محاور المحور
الجنوبي والمحور الشمالي همم درجه الحول
سيطره قوات بادنر على مدينه
[موسيقى]
همم او من عدمها يعني بالفعل يعني الجانب
الاوكراني همم اشار الى ان القوات الروسيه
لم تسيطر على هذه المدينه
يعني المقاتلين الاوكرانيين ماذا يدافعون
عن هذه المدينه دائما ما يدور جدل طاهر
حول يعني السيطره من عدمها على عده مدن
كما حصل في دار مثلا همم الدلائل توحي الى
انه هناك معارك ضاريه ااا يعني حرب شوارع
قتال شوارع في بعض المدن ينكر الجانب
الاوكراني والروسي اا يعني يخطوا خطوه
للامام ويقول بانه سيطر على هذه البدله
لكن بالفعل المعارك مستعره في المحور
الشمالي باكمله كما ان جنوب دانيسك ايضا
تشهد معارك داريه حول مدينه اوغلادار التي
سيطر على اطراف الجنوبيه والشرقيه الجيش
الروسي ويحاول الدخول او دخل فعلا حسب
تصريحات زعيمه الانفصاليا هنا همم
طاهر ان السلطات البلجيكيه همم منفذ
اعتداء المصاب بالتراب عقلي وكان هناك
اصابه لشخص لهذا الهجوم الذي نفذ بسكين في
بريكسال همم وبعد اعتقاله الان يبدو انه
مصاب بالتراب عقلي رائد في ما يخص مناطق
اول شيء
ههه بالاوكراني بتصيري رويدا او بالروسي
ههه
تضارب بهجمات الهجمات الناريه بين
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني ماذا في
التفاصيل وماذا عن الضحايا
لابد
راويه لابد في البدايه من العوده الى
تاريخ المنطقه كيف كانت القوات الروسيه
تسيطر على مدينه ليمان وكبيانس اطراف
مدينه او مقاطعه خارجي من ثم يعني اختلفت
موازين موازين القوى وانسحب الجيش الروسي
ليتمركز في اطراف في مدينه كريمنا ويتقدم
الجيش الاوكراني بالفعل وذلك كانت تزامنا
ايضا مع تقدمه في اخرصون وعوده الجيش
الروسي الى خرسون لكن مع عوده الجيش
الروسي بعد التعبئه الجزئيه والامداد
المنطقه باكملها بالجنود وبالاليات ادخال
اليات جديده بالفعل تغير الموقف واصبحت
القوات الروسيه تتقدم في عده محاور ومنها
ذلك المحور او المثلث النار كما نصفه حيث
ان القوات الاوكرانيه لديها حشود هناك وما
زالت تتقدم لكن الجيش الروسي ايضا يعني
وصلت اليه
في ذلك المحور ويحاول التقدم ربما تكون
اسخن المعارك هناك حتى ربما تكون اسخن من
معركه باخموت الدائره او معركه اوغلادار
لكن ننتظر من سينتصر في هذه المعركه لان
الدفاع الروسيه بشكل يومي تشير الى انها
تحيد اكثر من 100 جندي وعشرات الاليات
خاصه في هذا المحور لكن الحشود مستمره من
الطرفين الحديث عن اكثر من 40,000 مقاتل
اوكراني في ذلك المحور وروسيا ترسل
امدادات عسكريه بشريه وبالاليات ايضا الى
ذلك المحور شكرا لك رائد الاخضر مراسل
العربيه من دونيت شكرا لك
وقبل ان يغادر الملف الاوكراني بولس
جونسون يعود للواجهه في بريطانيا من بوابه
تصريحاته حول الحرب الاوكرانيه
بالصواريخ ليخرج المتحدث باسم الكرملين
وينتهمه بالكذب
[موسيقى]
لقد هددني في وقت ما وقال بوليس لا اريد
ان اذيك لكن بصاروخ سيستغرق الامر دقيقه
واحده فقط او شيئا من هذا القبيل
[موسيقى]
في محاوله لدفع جهود الحل في ليبيا عقد
وزير الخارجيه المغربي
ان الامم المتحده هي التي يمكنها حصريا
ايجاد حل في ليبيا بعيدا عن التدخلات
الاجنبيه في المغرب
وحدات ليبيا الوطنيه مع سيادتها الترابيه
حل اييه في اطار سياده ليبيا وحدتها
الترابيه وحدتها الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
تحتاج ليبيا الى الاستقرار بعد 10 سنوات
من الصراع فمن مصلحه الليبيين الليبيون
يعبرون عن هذا بطريقه قويه ويريدون مؤسسات
مستقره وذات شرعيه تفتح الطريق امام
ازدهار في بلدهم
على البقاء دائما على مسافه واحده من
الاطراف فيما ترى بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا ان الشرعيه في هذا البلد
لا يمكن حلها الا عبر انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه بعثته الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مع رئيسها الجديد تعتبر المغرب احد
الشركاء الدوليين في الملا في ليبيا فيما
الرباط ترى بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مظله لما سارين اثنين احتضنهما
المغرب حول الا في الليبيه مسارس خيرات
ومسار بوزنيقه عادل الزبير العربيه الرباط
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا في بيشاور باكستانيه
دخلوا للصالات فخرج واحد وستون منهم الى
مثواه الاخير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
المنافس الاقوى في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله وهو الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان صاحب الفتره الطويله في حكم هذه
البلاد فضلا عن المنافسه السياسيه فان
المواجهه بين المعارضه التركيه واردوغان
اخذ الطابعا دستوريا وقانونيه ايضا وذلك
من خلال التشكيك في قانونيه ترشحه لولايه
ثانيه المعارضه التركيه تقول ان ترشح
اردوغان يعد انتهاكا للدستور مشدده على
انه غير مؤهل قانونيا لانه سوف بالفعل
المدد الرئاسيه المسموح بها وهما ولايتان
لا يمكن ان يترشح لولايه الثالثه فهل
اردوغان غير مؤهل للترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه في تركيا هذا هو السؤال
الدخان يستند في موقفه على قاعده دستوريه
تسمح للرئيس بالترشح لاكثر من ولايتين في
حال تم اجراء انتخابات مبكرا وهو الحال
بالنسبه للانتخابات القادمه والتي بات من
المرتقب اجرائها في الرابعه عشر من ما
يؤلمبل غير ان معارضي ترشح اردوغان
يعتبرون ان هذه القاعده الدستوريه لاغيه
لان اجراء انتخابات مبكرا لم يتم بدعوه من
البرلمان بل من الرئيس التركي الذي استخدم
صلاحياته الدستوريه على الصعيد السياسي
تواصل المعارضه ترتيب اوراقها لاقناع
الناخبين تحالف المعارضه واصل تقديم
التعهدات في تحقيق نقل سياسيه واعتماد
توزيع جديد للسلطات في البلاد من اهم
الوعود التي اطلقها التحالف وارساء نظام
يخالف النظام الحالي الذي وضعه الرئيس
اردوغان وذلك بارساء نظام برلمانيا مع
رئيس بدور فخريا المنتخب لولايه واحده
تمتد على سبع سنوات
ميلادي اتفاقنا ميدان
السياسه المشتركه التي تم اعدادها في
مطابخ الاحزاب السياسيه السته التي تشكل
تحالف الامه المعروفه ايضا
والتي تتضمن اهدافا ملموسه واصلاحات
وسياسات ومشاريع ومن شانها اخراج بلدنا من
الازمه من اجل نظام برلماني متحرر
وديمقراطي وعادل يضمن الفصل بين السلطات
بدلا من هذا النظام الغريب الذي لا يعترف
باي قواعد
لغه الارقام قبيل الانتخابات
حيث اشارت نتائج استطلاعات للراي اجرتها
مؤسسات تركيه متخصصه ان حزب العداله
والتنميه سيتصدر نتائج الانتخابات
البرلمانيه وان الرئيس اردوغان سيفوز
بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه متقدما على خصومه
التقليديين وتوقع استطلاع للراي اجره مركز
كومبا ان يصوتا نحو 38 بالمئه لاردوغان
للفوز بمنصب الرئيس في حين قال 34% انهم
يمنحون اصواتهم لرئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
المعارض كماللو استطلاعته رائيا اخرى
توقعت النتيجه ذاتها وهي فوز اردوغان من
بينها استطلاع مؤسسه سوسيو ميديا حيث اكد
36% من المستطاعتي ارائهم انهم سيختارون
اردوغان لولايه جديده بينما جاء في
المرتبه الثانيه رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
بنسبه الثلاثه اما استطلاع الراي الذي
اجراه مركز اوراسيا فقد توقع فوز حزب
الشعب جمهوري بالانتخابات البرلمانيه لكنه
تنبا بفوز اردوغان بانتخابات الرئاسيه
وفيما يتعلق بنتائج الاستطلاعات التي
اجرتها من الصف تويتر والتي بلغ عددها 16
استطلاعا فقد اكد التقدم اردوغان بفارق
مريح نسبيا عن كمال كليتش دار اوبلوب
[موسيقى]
البرلماني افضل في السابق كانت انظمه
والقوانين تدافع عن حقوق الشعب وليس عن
الاشخاص حاليا ما يقوله شخص واحد هو الذي
يسري
ازمات كثيره لذلك انا اؤيد ان يكون الرئيس
متحكما بكل شيء
لتدخل 40 شخص حاليا
اكمل رجل واحد
اذا مجلس الدومه الروسيه يكشف عن مقترح
امريكي لاعلان منطقه منزوعه السلاح في
اوكرانيا لا شك خبر مهم متابعه تفاصيله
عندما ترد والى مراسلنا من انقره زيدان
اهلا بك زيدان يعني والثلوج تتساقط
عليك يعني اخبرنا عن ماذا على ماذا يختلف
همم اطراف الطاوله السداسيه او تحالف
الامه على ماذا يختلفون بما يخص اسم
المرشح لمنافسه اردوغان
نعم لا شك ان الثقه الاكبر راويه في
الطاوله السداسيه هو لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
اكبر احزاب المعارضه وبالتالي غالبيه او
معظم المرشحين المحتملين لمنافسه اردوغان
هم من هذا الحزب حزب الشعب الجمهوري
ونتحدث تحديدا عن كمال جدار اوبن رئيس
الحزب ومنصوريه واش رئيس بلديه انقره التي
نتواجد فيها وايضا اكرم امام اوغلو رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول وكلاء المرشحين الاخرين يا
واش وامام اوغلو حققه نتائج ايجابيه في
الانتخابات البلديه وتقدموا بفارق مريح
على مرشحي حزب العداله والتنميه في انقره
واسطنبول وبالتالي استطلاعات الراي التي
ذكرتموها قبل قليل هي المشكله كل
استطلاعات الرئيس تؤكد انه في حال ترشح
كمال كل الجدار اوبلو لمنافسه اردوغان فان
فرصه في الفوز قليل جدا وبالتالي همم في
حال تم اختيار امام اوغلو او منصور واش
المنافسه اردوغان ربما راسه وهم ستكون
اكبر بكثير من كمال كلشغار اوغلو من همم
في منافسه اردوغان ربما يضطر اردوغا
اردوغان للذهاب الى جوله ثانيه في حال كان
يواش او امام اوغلو هما احدهما طبعا هو
المرشح المنافس لاردوغان لكن في حال ترشح
كمايكل جدار اوغلو فان اردوغان ربما يذهب
او يفوز من الجوله الاولى وبالتالي هذه هي
النقطه الخلافيه الاساسيه في الطاوله
السداسيه وهي ما اخرت رغم كل التاكيدات
التي همم اصدرها زعماء هذه الطالبه انه لا
يوجد اي مشكله همم في ترشح همم او في
الاختيار مرشح مشترك لكن التصرفات
والافعال التي نشاهدها على ارض الواقع
التمبا بغير ذلك هناك خلافات حقيقيه في
الطاوله المستديره
وكما يقولون عقده المنشار هي المرشح
المشترك وكما كل جدار اوغلو يرفض يرفض
تماما ترشيح امام اوغلو او او منصوريه
منافسه اردوغان ويسر على اكثر التقدم هو
والت مقابل اردوغان همم زيدان همم وجود
شخصيات قياديه كبرى كانت في صف همم
اردوغان من قبل مع شخصيات المعارضه حاليا
ان كان احمد داوود اوغلو او علي بابا جان
او موقف عبد الله جول معروف او الى ما
هنالك الى اي مدى يؤثر سلبا في هذه اجابه
في هذه المعارضه او سلبا حيث يشتتها
ويفرقها لان الهويات مختلفه جدا الان
بينها
نعم لا شك انه هذه النقطه حتى الان غير
معروف غير معروف نحن نتحدث عن همم شخصيات
تمثل نوعا ما بيئه محفظه او نتحدث عن يمين
الوسط تتحالف مع همم التيار العلماني او
اليسار همم نتحدث عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري
او الحزب الديمقراطي في الطاوله السداسيه
هذا ما سيضع ناخبه حزب المستقبل بدعامه
احمد داوود اوغلو وايضا حزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم بزعامه عليبه بجانب في حيره يعني
كل المؤشرات تتحدث الى من سيصوت هؤلاء
الناخبين هل سوف يصوطون الى الخصم
التقليدي والعدو القديم الذي كان يحارب
المحافظين وهو حسب الشعب الجمهوري ام ين-
ام ينحازون الى زعماءهم همم وعلى مبدا لا
عدو دائم في السياسه الى هذا التحالف هذه
هي السؤال حقيقه سؤال كبير هذا ما ستكشف
عنه نتائج الانتخابات لمعرفه من سيصوت
هؤلاء مثلا في الانتخابات المحليه الماضيه
صوت من قسم كبير من المحافظين الى اكرم
امام اوغلو الذي ينحدر من حزب الشعب
الجمهوري لكن شخصيه اكرم امام اوغلو هي
الشخصيه نوعا ما لا يعني اكمل صحيح انه
ينتمي الى حزب الشعب الجمهوري لكن هو
شخصيه قوميه من جذور قوميه بالاساس
وبالتالي هذا ما شجع المحافظين على
التصويت له لكن شخصيه كماك الجدار اوغلو
مختلفه تماما عن همم بالتالي هذا السؤال
المحير
اسم كمال اوغلو ليست لديه حظوظ مثل نظيره
ولكن همم ماذا عن شعبيته بين الناس ماذا
عن علاقاته مع باقي الاحزاب والاطراف
التركيه يعني ما الذي يمتلكه هذا الرجل من
كاريزما ربما من علاقات من وزن يمكن ان
يعطيه او لا يعطيه حظوظا
باختصار لو سمحت
حاليا نعم باختصار هو اكبر زعماء المعارضه
بالتالي الكتله الكماليه او الكماليين في
تركيا لهذا الحزب وتقريبا هذه النسبه
تتراوح ما بين 20 الى 25 في المئه هذه
النسبه لا يمتلكها اي حزم من احزاب
المعادله وبالتالي قسم كبير من احزاب
المعاظه بحاجه للتحالف محكمه اما عن شخصيه
كمال
شخصيه اليساريه العلمانيه التي تلبي
تطلعات قسم معين من شارع التركي في
السنوات الاخيره حاول التقرب من المحافظين
وكان يشارك في كثير من الانشطه التي تهم
المحافظين والقوميين هنا في تركيا في
محاوله لكسب اصوات هؤلاء لكن في المقابل
هناك همم تاريخ هذا الرجل تاريخ كمال في
ما يخص موضوع الحجاب تحديدا وعندما قررت
قرر حزب العداله والتنميه السماح للمحجبات
بدخول همم المؤسسات الحكوميه كان له موقف
معارض لهذا الموضوع وهذا الموقف ليس ببعيد
عشر سنوات تقريبا لا اكثر لذلك تاريخ همم
كمال الجدار اوغلو قبل همم ان يقرر الترشح
لمنافسه اردوغان مخالف تماما
للتاريخ الذي تلا هذا القرار وبالتالي
يتحدث عن السنه الماضيه والشهور الماضيه
عندما غير كثيرا من تكتيكه وحاولت من
التقرب للمحافظين شكرا جزيلا لك زيدان
زينكو مراسل العربيه من انقره شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا اقاله ريسي سوناك للوزير
ورئيس حزب المحافظين ناظم زهاوي لا تزالوا
تثير ردود فعل متعدده
انه جاء بعد تحقيق مستقلا قال لا حول
الافاعي انا لديهم مخاوف من طريقه اقالته
لم يحسم جدله اقاله الناظم الزهاوي من
منصبه في الحكومه ومن رئاسه حزب المحافظين
مع تعالي اصوات منتقده للاستعجال في فصله
من الحكومه واخرى معارضه للتاخير في فصله
من منصبه الوزاري رغم الوقائع ثابته
الاسئله تتزايد بشان طرد الزهاوي من
الحكومه بينما يتمسك ريش سوناك بانه تصرف
بشكل صحيح ونزيه بعد تحقيق مستقل في
ملابساته الضريبيه استغرق اسبوع فقط واخلص
الى ان الزهاوي خرق قواعد وزاريه
وما فعلته بمجرد علم بالقضيه هو تعيين شخص
مستقل للنظر في القمر
منصفا للتاكد من ان الحقائق
محددهم قال حلفاء لزهراوي ان لديهم خوف من
الطريقه التي جرى بها التحقيق والذي ادى
الى اقالته المعارضه وصلت توجيها سهام
انتقاداتها الى سوناك مطالبه بالكشف عن ما
كان يعرفه عن وضع هوي قبل تعيينه في
الحكومه في ما قضايا التنمر وتصرفات بعض
الوزاراء تلاحق مصداقيه ونزاهه سوناك التي
تعاهد بها لحظه اختياره مصطفى زارو
العربيه لندن
قبل ان ننتقل الى الرياضه مجلس قبائل
ليبيا يقول سنغلق حقول النفط والغاز بعد
اتفاق حكومه البيبه مع ايطاليا وكذلك
الاتفاق غير الشرعيه بين البيبه وايطاليا
هو سبب ما تقوله او يقوله مجلس قبائل
الامريكي وقالت انه اعلان منطقه سلاح في
اوكرانيا لم تنطاليه
من الواضح ان كان يستطيع ان يفكر اصلا قبل
دقائق كان في المسجد يصلي كان مع اصدقائه
متراصين داخل مسجد في المقر العام لشرطه
المدينه
المنوره
اخر
ربما هذا يفكر فيه الان يريد ان يقول لقد
كنا فقط نصل
وفي تصريح اليوم
الولايات المتحده هي المستفيد الاول من
الحرب في اوكرانيا التصريح حوالي نائب
وزير الخارجيه روسي سيريا كاظم الذي اضاف
ايضا انه واشنطن تعتبر اوكرانيا حقل
تجاربن صناعتها العسكريه
لكنها ايضا
في ازهى فتراتها
فيديو اليوم لماذا يجب ان يكونوا دائما
حدثي المنزل على اريكه قديمه تحت ضوء خافت
وبملابس بهت تاريخ صنعها وضع الفنان
النيجيري مالك افجباو بمساعده الذكاء
الاصطناعي اباءنا وامهاتنا اجدادنا وجدتنا
في مكان يغمره الضوء على خشبه عروض
الازياء
وضعهم في مكان يستحقونه وان كانوا بالطبع
يستحقون اكثر
رائع على الصور
الان الى زميله ميسون نويهد ومعها اخبار
الساعه مساء الخير ميسون ماذا لديك الليله
اليوم سنتحدث عن تصريحات مكروم بعدم
استبعاد ارسال مقاتلات الى اوكرانيا ايضا
روبرت مالي يقول بانه سيمنع ايران من
امتلاك النووي عسكريه بحال فشلت
الدبلوماسيه وايضا
في البوكمال بعد الضربات للتعرض لها
بالاضافه الى العديد من الاخبار تابعونا
[موسيقى]